Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishist'Artagnan had the key, they saw Monsieur de Saint-Mars directing his steps towards the chamber inhabited by the prisoner. Upon a sign from D'Artagnan, they concealed themselves in an angle of the staircase. What is it? said Athos. You will see, look, the prisoner is returning from chapel. And they saw, by the red flashes of lightning against the violet fog which the wind stamped on the bankwood sky, they saw pass pass gravely, at six paces behind the governor, a man, clothed in black and masked by a visor of
感谢您收听《历史就是如此》。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishist。达达尼昂拿着钥匙，他们看到圣马尔先生正朝着囚犯居住的房间走去。在达达尼昂的示意下，他们躲在楼梯的拐角处。“怎么了？”阿托斯问道。“你会看到的，看，囚犯正从礼拜堂回来。”他们看到，在风吹过班克伍德天空的紫色雾气中，闪电发出红色的光芒，他们看到在总督身后六步远的地方，一个男人庄重地走过，他身穿黑衣，戴着一个面罩，
polished steel, soldered to a helmet of the same nature, which altogether enveloped the whole of his head. The fire of the heavens cast red reflections on the polished surface, and these reflections, flying off capriciously, seemed to be angry looks launched by the unfortunate instead of imprecations. In the middle of the gallery, the prisoner stopped for a moment to contemplate the infinite horizon, to respire the sulphurous perfumes of the tempest, to drink in thirstily the hot rain, and to breathe a sigh resembling a smothered groan. So that was The Man in the Iron Mask by Alexandre Dumas, which is a subsection of a colossal novel called The Vicomte of Bragelonne, which is the third in the series of novels that begins with the three musketeers,
抛光的钢制面罩焊接在一个同样材质的头盔上，完全包裹住了他的整个头部。天上的火光在抛光的表面上投下红色的倒影，这些倒影反复无常地飞散，看起来像是那个不幸的人发出的愤怒的目光，而不是诅咒。在长廊中间，囚犯停了一会儿，凝视着无限的地平线，呼吸着暴风雨中硫磺的气味，贪婪地喝着热雨，并发出了一声类似于被压抑的呻吟的叹息。这就是亚历山大·仲马的《铁面人》，它是那部宏伟小说《布拉热洛纳子爵》的一个小节，这是以《三个火枪手》开头的小说系列中的第三部，
all for one and one for all. Tom, are you a big Three Musketeers fan? I loved it. Didn't you? All that floppy hats, feathers, flashing rapiers, milady with the long black cloak and the beauty spot. Brilliant. Loved it. The one that I'm familiar with is the Oliver Reed. Yeah. Is he Porthos? Yeah. I think he is Porthos. Because he's the one who goes, oh, and he's kind of large, isn't he?
“人人为我，我为人人”。汤姆，你是《三个火枪手》的超级粉丝吗？我喜欢它。你不喜欢吗？那些软塌塌的帽子、羽毛、闪烁的刺剑、穿着长黑斗篷和长着美人痣的米莱狄。太棒了。我很喜欢。我熟悉的是奥利弗·里德那一版。是的。他是波托斯吗？是的。我想他是波托斯。因为他是那个会说“哦”的人，而且他长得比较壮，不是吗？
Yes, he is. And d'Artagnan, he's the embodiment of Savoie Faire, of French Dash. Yeah. Flashing Gaskin blade. He's like Theo, our producer, who purports to be French. Very similar. Yeah, he is. Yeah.
是的，他是。还有达达尼昂，他是“处世之道”和“法式风度”的化身。是的。闪烁的加斯科涅之刃。他就像我们的制片人西奥，他自称是法国人。非常相似。是的，他就是。是的。
He is. Exactly so. And so the Three Musketeers, incredibly famous, and I had always assumed were fictional. Mais au contraire. No. Really? D'Artagnan was a real person? D'Artagnan was a real person.
他确实是。正是如此。所以《三个火枪手》非常出名，我一直以为是虚构的。但恰恰相反。不。真的吗？达达尼昂是一个真实存在的人？达达尼昂是一个真实存在的人。
He ended up captain of the Musketeers. Yeah. And he dies fighting for Louis XIV against the Dutch. So you'd probably approve of that, wouldn't you? I mean, a kind of martyr's death. It's a pity they can't both lose to him. So D'Artagnan is real. San Marz, the jailer in that passage, he is also real. But the question we're going to be exploring today is the man in the iron mask, is he real?
他最终成为了火枪队长。是的。他在为路易十四对抗荷兰人的战斗中阵亡。所以你可能会赞同这一点，不是吗？我的意思是，一种殉道者的死亡。可惜他们不能都输给他。所以达达尼昂是真实的。圣马尔，那段文字里的狱卒，他也是真实的。但我们今天要探讨的问题是，铁面人，他是真实的吗？
So the man in the iron mask, I have to confess right at the outset, like most people, I'm sort of vaguely aware of the man in the iron mask in the fact that he's a man, he wears an eye mask and he's locked up for a long time. And I remember seeing the film where I think Guy Pearce was in it. I can't remember who else was in it. It was Leonardo DiCaprio. Leonardo DiCaprio. Yes.
所以关于铁面人，我必须在一开始就承认，像大多数人一样，我只是模糊地知道铁面人，知道他是一个男人，戴着铁面具，被关了很长时间。我记得看过一部电影，我想盖·皮尔斯在里面。我不记得还有谁在里面了。是莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥。莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥。是的。
But other than that, I'm actually quite ignorant of this subject, Tom. Despite having heard me talk about it four times on the stage. Let me rephrase that. I'm going to pretend to be quite ignorant for the purposes of the podcast, because I always put the podcast first above my own personal prestige. So to explain to people, we've been on a tour of Australia and New Zealand, haven't we? Before that, we did a couple of shows in England. And in four of those, we did a kind of live show based around The Man in the Iron Mask.
但除此之外，我对这个主题其实很无知，汤姆。尽管你已经听过我在舞台上谈论过它四次了。让我换个说法。为了播客的目的，我要假装我很无知，因为我总是把播客放在我个人的声望之上。所以向大家解释一下，我们一直在澳大利亚和新西兰巡演，不是吗？在那之前，我们在英国做了几场演出。在其中四场中，我们做了一个关于《铁面人》的现场秀。
Because I was always fascinated by it. So I did love The Three Musketeers stories. But I was also, I had a paperback book of mysteries that was kind of mysteries from history. So there was a ghostly Roman legion that was spotted in York. Oh, yes. Yeah. The Mary Celeste. Yeah.
因为我一直对它很着迷。所以我确实喜欢《三个火枪手》的故事。但我也有一本平装的神秘书，是关于历史上的神秘事件。所以有在约克发现的幽灵罗马军团。哦，是的。是的。玛丽·塞莱斯特号。是的。
El Dorado, things like that. Is that the Earthborn book? I think I had that book. No, it wasn't. It was a kind of small paperback book, but on the cover they had the man in the iron mask and it was a terrifying image. Right. You know, I'd kind of dare myself to look at it. So I've always been interested in it. And in this book, they had no doubt as to who the man in the iron mask was, that he was real. And I'll maybe reveal later on in the course of this episode who they thought it was.
黄金国，诸如此类的事情。那是厄斯伯恩的书吗？我想我有那本书。不，不是。那是一本小型的平装书，但封面上印着铁面人，那是一个可怕的形象。对。你知道，我曾敢于去看它。所以我一直对它很感兴趣。在那本书里，他们毫不怀疑铁面人是谁，他确实存在。也许我会在本集稍后揭露他们认为他是谁。
Okay. Because basically everything in that book was rubbish. Oh no. I came to realise, I kind of thought, well, maybe it wasn't true. But then doing the reading for the stage show that we were doing, I discovered actually he really did exist. Oh, excellent. And there's quite a lot of evidence as to who he really was.
好的。因为基本上那本书里的一切都是垃圾。哦，不。我开始意识到，我当时想，也许那不是真的。但后来在为我们做的舞台秀进行阅读时，我发现他确实存在。哦，太棒了。而且有很多证据表明他到底是谁。
Okay. So that's what we're going to be doing today. We're going to explore that. Talk us through it, Tom. And I will pretend consistently that I don't know what's coming. No, you don't have to. You don't have to. You don't have to.
好的。所以这就是我们今天要做的。我们要探讨这个问题。汤姆，给我们讲讲吧。我会一直假装我不知道接下来会发生什么。不，你不必。你不必。你不必。
But Dominic, you will remember from the stage show we did that there are three contemporaneous pieces of evidence that refer to a prisoner wearing, if not an iron mask, then a mask. Right. And the first of these dates to the 4th of September, 1687. And it is written by a bishop. So he's a Jansenist bishop, which is a kind of slightly heretical kind of bishop. And so he's having to communicate to his priests with written newspapers. And this gazette that he writes on the 4th of September 1687 records the appearance
但是多米尼克，你会从我们做的舞台秀中记得，有三份同时代的证据提到了一个囚犯戴着面具，如果不是铁面具的话。对。其中第一份可以追溯到1687年9月4日。它是由一位主教写的。所以他是一位詹森派主教，这是一种稍微有点异端的教派。所以他不得不通过书面报纸与他的牧师们交流。他在1687年9月4日写的这份公报记录了
on the south coast of France by Cannes, so scene of the film festival, of an unknown man who's been brought from a prison in the Alps, a place called Exiles, by this guy, Saint-Mars, who is a top jailer. We love a top jailer. Yeah. So Saint-Mars has brought this prisoner all the way down to the coast by Cannes and they're preparing to board a ship and go over to this island called Saint-Marguerite, which is a prison island. So once you're on it, you can't escape it. Right. And the bishop in his gazette reports that this mysterious prisoner is a prisoner of the
在法国南部戛纳附近，也就是电影节的举办地，出现了一个身份不明的男人，他是由这个叫圣马尔的家伙从阿尔卑斯山的一座监狱，一个叫埃克西尔的地方带来的，他是一个顶级狱卒。我们喜欢顶级狱卒。是的。所以圣马尔把这个囚犯一路带到了戛纳附近的海岸，他们正准备登上一艘船，前往一个叫圣玛格丽特岛的地方，那是一个监狱岛。所以一旦你上了岛，你就逃不掉了。对。主教在他的公报中报告说，这个神秘的囚犯是国家的囚犯。
state. So he's been condemned on the personal orders of the king and that he has been transported by san marz in conditions of the utmost secrecy right so no one has been allowed to know his name yeah he's been carried the whole way down from the alps down to the south coast in a sedan chair swathed in kind of black cloth so very stifling yeah i mean you know hot time of the year yeah and the whole way he has worn a mask d'acier a mask of steel so that even when the sedan chair is laid down to rest on the docks by can yeah and the prisoner gets out and steps into the boat people still can't see who he is because he is wearing this mask so to give you a preview of the next episode we're doing tom he looks a little bit like clitus in flash Gordon, played by Peter Wingard, who has sort of metal mask on the whole time. Anyway, that's by the by. Or perhaps Darth Vader,
所以他是根据国王的个人命令被判刑的，并且是由圣马尔在极其保密的情况下转移的，所以没有人被允许知道他的名字。是的，他一路从阿尔卑斯山被带到南海岸，坐在一个用黑布包裹的轿子里，所以非常闷热。是的，我的意思是，你知道，一年中很热的时候。是的，而且他全程都戴着钢制面具，所以即使当轿子被放下在戛纳码头休息时，囚犯走出来登上船，人们仍然看不出他是谁，因为他戴着这个面具。所以为了给你预告一下我们下一集要做的内容，汤姆，他看起来有点像《飞侠哥顿》里的克利图斯，由彼得·温加德饰演，他一直戴着某种金属面具。总之，那是题外话。或者也许是达斯·维达，
who also features in it. Yes, giving people an exciting preview of what is coming. Anyway. Yes. So what happens to the prisoner? Well, he vanishes from public record after that fleeting mention for 12 years. And then 18th of September, 1698, an entry is made in a register that is kept at the Bastille. And the Bastille, of course, will be familiar to all fans of the French Revolution, the prison that gets stormed in 1789. But this is well before that. The Bastille is the great royal stronghold in the heart of Paris. And this register is kept by one of the jailers there, a guy called Etienne de Juncker. And he records the arrival from the island of Saint-Marguerite, so that prison island of Cannes, of the new governor of the Bastille. And who should this new governor of the Bastille be, Dominic? But Monsieur de Saint-Mars.
他也出现在里面。是的，给人们一个关于即将发生的事情的激动人心的预告。总之。是的。那么囚犯发生了什么事？好吧，在那次短暂的提及之后，他在公共记录中消失了12年。然后是1698年9月18日，巴士底狱保存的一份登记册上做了一个条目。当然，巴士底狱对于所有法国大革命的粉丝来说都很熟悉，那是1789年被攻占的监狱。但这在那之前很久。巴士底狱是巴黎市中心伟大的皇家堡垒。这份登记册是由那里的狱卒之一，一个叫艾蒂安·德·容克的家伙保存的。他记录了从圣玛格丽特岛，也就是戛纳那个监狱岛，来的巴士底狱新任总督的到来。多米尼克，这位巴士底狱的新总督会是谁呢？正是圣马尔先生。
Who would have guessed? Our old friend. And he has brought a prisoner with him. And the name of this prisoner is never uttered, so nobody knows who he is. And Dionca reports the prisoner is always masked. And he is taken into the Bastille and again, vanishes from the public record. Until five years later on the 20th of November, 1703, Gianco makes another entry in the register. And this time he is recording the death the previous day. So the 19th of November
谁能猜到呢？我们的老朋友。他带了一个囚犯来。这个囚犯的名字从未被说出，所以没有人知道他是谁。德·容克报告说囚犯总是戴着面具。他被带进巴士底狱，再次从公共记录中消失。直到五年后的1703年11月20日，德·容克在登记册上做了另一个条目。这一次他记录的是前一天的死亡。所以11月19日
of this prisoner, the unknown prisoner, as he's described. And that afternoon of the 20th of November, so the shadows are spreading, in a nearby graveyard, the prisoner is buried in an unmarked grave. And at this point, de Juncker specifies that the mask that the prisoner is wearing is made not of steel, as the bishop had reported, but of black velvet. Very different connotations of a mask of black velvet, I would say, Tom. Yes, so there's some confusion there, but both are agreeing that he is wearing a mask and that he is not named. Although, intriguingly, a later entry by de Jonquay,
这个囚犯，也就是被描述为身份不明的囚犯。11月20日那天下午，阴影正在蔓延，在附近的一个墓地里，囚犯被埋葬在一个无名墓中。在这一点上，德·容克明确指出，囚犯戴的面具不是主教所报告的钢制的，而是黑天鹅绒的。汤姆，我觉得黑天鹅绒面具的含义非常不同。是的，所以那里有一些混乱，但两者都同意他戴着面具，而且他没有名字。尽管，有趣的是，德·容克后来的一条记录，
so he's written it in the margin in different ink, records the name of this prisoner. And the name that is given is Monsieur de Marchiel. Okay. So is this the name? I mean. Is that his name? Yeah.
所以他用不同的墨水写在页边空白处，记录了这个囚犯的名字。给出的名字是马尔基尔先生。好的。所以这是他的名字吗？我的意思是。那是他的名字吗？是的。
But I mean, essentially, it's a pretty anonymous prisoner. If Marchiel is not actually his name, then he's completely anonymous. Yeah. And he's being buried in this wintry twilight. And by rights, his memory should have been utterly consigned to oblivion. But of course, it hasn't been because the identity of this mysterious prisoner described as wearing a mask either of steel or of black velvet has become one of the great mysteries in all history.
但我的意思是，本质上，他是一个相当匿名的囚犯。如果马尔基尔实际上不是他的名字，那么他就是完全匿名的。是的。他被埋葬在这个冬日的黄昏里。按理说，他的记忆应该被彻底遗忘。但当然，它并没有被遗忘，因为这个被描述为戴着钢制或黑天鹅绒面具的神秘囚犯的身份，已经成为历史上最伟大的谜团之一。
And this is the man in the iron mask. So the question, who is he? And why does he come to be described as wearing an iron mask? It's a good subject. So, Tom, let's do a bit of context. Where are we again? Late 17th century, early 18th. Tall in the reign of Louis XIV.
这就是铁面人。所以问题是，他是谁？为什么他会被描述为戴着铁面具？这是一个很好的主题。所以，汤姆，让我们做一点背景介绍。我们又在哪里？17世纪末，18世纪初。路易十四统治时期。
Louis XIV's France. And Louis XIV, what did he reign from? 1638 to 1715. So, 72 years. Le roi soleil, Theo is reminding me. The sun king. The French producer sticking up for his monarch because of course louis the 14th ruled longer even than our own late beloved queen oh
路易十四的法国。路易十四，他统治了多久？1638年到1715年。所以，72年。太阳王，西奥在提醒我。太阳王。法国制片人支持他的君主，因为当然路易十四的统治时间甚至比我们已故的挚爱女王还要长。哦，
that's poor isn't it if she'd held out for two more years she would have pipped him that's bad form from louis the 14th because also he took over as a baby so i think that's cheating isn't it that is cheating that's absolutely cheating so this is obviously the heyday of the wig, the rapier. Yeah. Fountains. The bubbling fountain. The ridiculous court hierarchy of Versailles and stuff. It's French absolutism.
那很糟糕，不是吗？如果她再坚持两年，她就会超过他。路易十四这样做很不厚道，因为他也是从婴儿时期就开始统治的，所以我认为那是作弊，不是吗？那是作弊，绝对是作弊。所以这显然是假发、刺剑的鼎盛时期。是的。喷泉。冒泡的喷泉。凡尔赛宫荒谬的宫廷等级制度等等。这是法国的绝对君主制。
Yes. Yes. Cardinal Richelieu, Cardinal Mazarin. Waves of cardinals. Yeah. But I think the key issue and why Louis XIV provides such a telling context for the man in the iron mask is, as you said, this is the era of royal absolutism, which is a trend that has been building in France for many centuries. I mean, going right the way back to the time of the Hundred Years' War, which we talked about, but has particularly intensified in the 17th century under Louis XIV and before him, his father, Louis XIII, guided by, as you say, the cardinals, first Richelieu and then Mazarin. And when Louis comes to the throne, noblemen who have been resentful of royal control
是的。是的。黎塞留红衣主教，马扎然红衣主教。红衣主教的浪潮。是的。但我认为关键问题，以及为什么路易十四为铁面人提供了如此有力的背景，正如你所说，这是皇家绝对主义的时代，这是法国几个世纪以来一直在形成的趋势。我的意思是，一直追溯到我们谈到的百年战争时期，但在17世纪路易十四统治下，以及在他之前的父亲路易十三统治下，在正如你所说的红衣主教，先是黎塞留，然后是马扎然的指导下，这种趋势尤为强烈。当路易登上王位时，那些对皇家控制感到不满的贵族
under Louis XIII, they start making trouble. Because if you have a boy on the throne, then there's opportunities. And when Louis is 10, so in 1648, this kind of basically an attempt to throw off the shackles of royal absolutism that comes to be known as the Fronde breaks out. And it takes its name from the French for sling because crowds gather with slings in the streets of Paris and use their slings to kind of break the windows of supporters of Mazarin, who is seen as this kind of sinister controlling spider behind the throne. And Louis' government, he's got the nobility, he's got various royal princes, he's got the parliament, the law courts, and they're all against him. But he emerges triumphant, and he's absolutely resolved that never again will he face an analogous threat.
在路易十三统治下，他们开始制造麻烦。因为如果你有一个男孩在王位上，那么就有机会。当路易10岁时，也就是1648年，这种基本上试图摆脱皇家绝对主义枷锁的运动爆发了，被称为“投石党运动”。它得名于法语中的“投石索”，因为人群在巴黎街头聚集，用投石索打破马扎然支持者的窗户，马扎然被视为王位背后那个邪恶的控制蜘蛛。路易的政府，他有贵族，他有各种皇室王子，他有议会，他有法院，他们都反对他。但他最终取得了胜利，他绝对下定决心，再也不会面临类似的威胁。
I suppose he's also thinking about what's been happening in Britain, right? In England, Scotland and Ireland. Of course. The wars and yeah. Absolutely. And so the great symbol of this resolve is, as you said, the Palace of Versailles, which is built shortly after. So Versailles, it's 12 miles west of Paris, 13 miles west of Paris, something like that.
我想他也在考虑英国发生的事情，对吧？在英格兰、苏格兰和爱尔兰。当然。战争和是的。绝对是。所以这种决心的伟大象征，正如你所说，是凡尔赛宫，它是在那之后不久建造的。所以凡尔赛宫，它在巴黎以西12英里，巴黎以西13英里，诸如此类。
And it had originally been used by Louis XIII as a hunting lodge. And then he'd kind of had it built up into a chateau. But Louis XIV builds it into this kind of enormous palace. I mean, lots of people will have visited if you haven't. I mean, it's one of the great tourist attractions in the world. And it's commissioned almost a decade after the front has been brought to an end. And it's inspired specifically by a visit Louis makes to a palace that is owned by basically his kind of financial guru, the superintendent of finances, a guy called Nicolas Fouquet. And Fouquet, using his position as the guy in charge of France's finances, is spectacularly wealthy. And the castle and the entertainments that he lays on stupefy Louis. And this, of course, is very foolish because Louis is, I mean,
它最初被路易十三用作狩猎小屋。然后他把它建成了一座城堡。但路易十四把它建成了一座巨大的宫殿。我的意思是，很多人都去参观过，如果你没去过的话。我的意思是，它是世界上最伟大的旅游景点之一。它是在投石党运动结束近十年后委托建造的。它的灵感特别来自于路易对一座宫殿的访问，那座宫殿基本上属于他的财务大师，财务总监，一个叫尼古拉·富凯的家伙。富凯利用他作为负责法国财务的人的职位，极其富有。他建造的城堡和举办的娱乐活动让路易目瞪口呆。当然，这非常愚蠢，因为路易，我的意思是，
he's determined, first of all, to build Versailles to put Fouquet's palace in the shade. But he's also alarmed that Fouquet may be corrupt and may be using the money that he's skimming off to kind of build up a rival power base to the king himself. And so a month later, Fouquet is arrested by none other than D'Artagnan. Oh, no way. Yeah. So D'Artagnan is actually quite a bad fellow. He's a henchman. No, he's obeying the king's orders. I mean, he's a loyal servant of the king. He's the head of the musketeers. He's a henchman, Tom. He's a hired goon. No, he's loyal to his king. I mean, he has sworn an oath. Yeah.
他首先决心建造凡尔赛宫，让富凯的宫殿黯然失色。但他也很担心富凯可能腐败，可能正在利用他贪污的钱来建立一个与国王本人抗衡的权力基础。所以一个月后，富凯被达达尼昂逮捕了。哦，不会吧。是的。所以达达尼昂实际上是个坏家伙。他是个走狗。不，他是在服从国王的命令。我的意思是，他是国王的忠实仆人。他是火枪队长。他是个走狗，汤姆。他是个雇佣打手。不，他忠于他的国王。我的意思是，他发过誓。是的。
He's dashing. He's got a great moustache and beard. Of course, he's not a goon. Terrible thing to say. So, poor old Fouquet is put on trial, and the trial lasts three years. And at the end of it, he is convicted, and he's sentenced to be exiled from all the centres of power. And again, d'Artagnan escorts him all the way from Paris down to the Alps, where there is a royal fortress called Pignerol, which stands near the Italian border, guarding the road that leads down into Italy. He arrives there in December, 1664, and d'Artagnan
他很潇洒。他有一撇很棒的胡子。当然，他不是打手。说这种话太糟糕了。所以，可怜的富凯被送上法庭，审判持续了三年。最后，他被定罪，并被判处流放，远离所有权力中心。同样，达达尼昂护送他从巴黎一路到阿尔卑斯山，那里有一座皇家堡垒叫皮内罗洛，靠近意大利边境，守卫着通往意大利的道路。他于1664年12月到达那里，达达尼昂
hands him over to the commander of this royal fortress. And who is the commander of this royal fortress? If not, our old friend, Monsieur de Saint-Mars. I have no sense of Monsieur de Saint-Mars. Paint a picture of him for me, Tom. Okay. So Saint-Mars is a guy who basically goes around a succession of royal fortresses and into these royal fortresses, various prisoners are sent. So he is commanded pina roll yeah when fouquet gets sent to him he commands exiles which is the fortress from which he brings the man in the iron mask san margarit and then the bastille and the bastille obviously is you know if you're a jailer that is the one that you ultimately want to command so basically
把他交给了这座皇家堡垒的指挥官。这座皇家堡垒的指挥官是谁？如果不是我们的老朋友，圣马尔先生的话。我对圣马尔先生没有任何概念。汤姆，给我描绘一下他的形象。好的。所以圣马尔是一个基本上在各个皇家堡垒之间奔波的家伙，各种囚犯被送进这些皇家堡垒。所以他指挥皮内罗洛，是的，当富凯被送给他时，他指挥埃克西尔，也就是他带来铁面人的那个堡垒，圣玛格丽特，然后是巴士底狱，当然，如果你是一个狱卒，那是你最终想要指挥的，所以基本上
he reaches the top of the jailer tree he's not one of those sort of great jailers, you know, who'd be played by, I don't know who would play him, John Candy. No. A big sweating man with a massive ring of keys. No, I think it's more the kind of, you know, the banality of evil kind of guy. Ah. He's not evil.
他达到了狱卒职业的顶峰。他不是那种伟大的狱卒，你知道，那种会被，我不知道谁会演他，约翰·坎迪。不。一个大汗淋漓、戴着一大串钥匙的男人。不，我认为他更像是那种，你知道，平庸的邪恶那种人。啊。他不邪恶。
He's not evil. But I mean, he's basically an apparatchik. Right, right. I mean, he's not a musketeer. Yeah. You know, he's not flashing his blade or that kind of thing. I mean, he is looking after prisoners in royal fortresses. He's trusted, but he's not a key player. But I mean, he is very close in the chain of command to Louis XIV himself. So if we think
他不邪恶。但我的意思是，他基本上是一个官僚。对，对。我的意思是，他不是火枪手。是的。你知道，他没有挥舞他的剑或类似的东西。我的意思是，他在皇家堡垒里照顾囚犯。他受到信任，但他不是关键人物。但我的意思是，他在指挥链上非常接近路易十四本人。所以如果我们想到
of Louis XIV, you know, the Le Roi Soleil, you think of the blaze of his light because he is ruler over France when France is at its absolute apogée. He is the dominant figure, not just in France, but in Europe as well. Yeah, of course. He's a great hate figure for the English, isn't he? But also kind of object of emulation. So in due course, the Duke of Marlborough, you know, he'll defeat Louis XIV's armies at the Battle of Blenheim and be awarded Blenheim Palace by a grateful nation. But Blenheim Palace is just, you know, I mean, it's a feeble echo of the splendor and glory of Versailles. Tom, this is unbelievable. Very poor.
路易十四，你知道，太阳王，你会想到他光芒的闪耀，因为当法国处于绝对巅峰时，他是法国的统治者。他不仅在法国，而且在欧洲也是主导人物。是的，当然。他是英国人的一个大仇人，不是吗？但也是一种效仿的对象。所以到了一定时候，马尔伯勒公爵，你知道，他将在布伦海姆战役中击败路易十四的军队，并被一个感恩的国家授予布伦海姆宫。但布伦海姆宫只是，你知道，我的意思是，它是凡尔赛宫辉煌和荣耀的微弱回声。汤姆，这太不可思议了。非常糟糕。
So Louis XIV, I mean, he's a domineering, powerful, glamorous figure, but he's also quite a sinister figure, I think. Right. Because am I not right in thinking that in the 1930s, let's say, there were some French historians who would say of Louis XIV, oh well, the sinister nature of his regime prefigures, I mean, maybe this is too strong, but slightly prefigures the detainment of the 20th century. People being thrown into prison, musketeers doing his bidding, a sort of sense of the absolutism, that an absolute monarchy is something to dread. Well, yes and no. It's absolutely true that people do vanish. People who offend Louis can kind of, you know, disappear into the prison system for years at a time. Although it's important to say that the prison system is obviously, you know, it's not a gulag system.
所以路易十四，我的意思是，他是一个专横、强大、迷人的人物，但我认为他也是一个相当阴险的人物。对。因为我没记错的话，在20世纪30年代，有一些法国历史学家会说路易十四，哦，好吧，他政权的阴险本质预示了，我的意思是，也许这太强烈了，但稍微预示了20世纪的拘留。人们被扔进监狱，火枪手听从他的命令，一种绝对主义的感觉，即绝对君主制是令人恐惧的东西。嗯，是的，也不是。人们确实会消失，这是绝对真实的。冒犯路易的人可以，你知道，在监狱系统中消失多年。虽然必须说监狱系统显然，你知道，它不是古拉格系统。
Yeah, sure. He said, I am the state. He wants to be the embodiment of the law. He doesn't want to feel that the law has no status whatsoever. And so although people can vanish, it's all done legally, as Louis would see it. So he issues these things that are called lettres de cachet. Right. So they're sealed letters, aren't they? Sealed letters. There is no need to specify what crime the offender has committed, nor is there any need to specify how long an offender can be imprisoned. And so we've already discussed this once before
是的，当然。他说，朕即国家。他想成为法律的化身。他不想觉得法律没有任何地位。所以虽然人们会消失，但这一切都是合法完成的，正如路易所认为的那样。所以他发布了被称为“密札”的东西。对。所以它们是密封的信件，不是吗？密封的信件。不需要说明罪犯犯了什么罪，也不需要说明罪犯可以被监禁多久。所以我们之前已经讨论过一次了
on The Rest Is History with reference to the Marquis de Sade. So if you remember, the Marquis de Sade's mother-in-law obtained a letter to Cachet from the king, and this is what enabled Sade to be imprisoned without a trial. And the chain of command that links a prisoner to the king is very, very short. So you have the prisoner, then you have Sam Mars, you know, or the jailer or whatever, who's looking after him. And then between the jailer and Louis, there is one other person who is the minister of war. And in the case of Louis XIV, this is a guy called the Marquis de Louvois, who's very, very able. I mean, this is the guy who is providing Louis with the war machine that enables him to throw his weight around and put all Europe in his shadow. Well, Europe's largest army. Yeah.
在《历史就是如此》中提到了萨德侯爵。所以如果你记得，萨德侯爵的岳母从国王那里获得了一封密札，这就是萨德在没有审判的情况下被监禁的原因。将囚犯与国王联系起来的指挥链非常非常短。所以你有囚犯，然后你有圣马尔，你知道，或者狱卒什么的，他在照顾他。然后在狱卒和路易之间，还有一个人，就是战争大臣。在路易十四的情况下，这是一个叫卢福瓦侯爵的家伙，他非常有能力。我的意思是，这个家伙正在为路易提供战争机器，使他能够炫耀武力，让整个欧洲都处于他的阴影之下。嗯，欧洲最大的军队。是的。
We love a cliche on the rest of his history. Surely not. And so this is, I think, why the man in the iron mask has such a resonance because he seems to kind of symbolize the darkness that is the counterpoint to the blaze of Versailles. This sense that anyone can vanish into one of the royal fortresses, that identity itself can be erased, and that once you are locked up in a fortress, there are eyes watching you all the time. So I think that in the 18th century, the man in the iron mask becomes a symbol of this. Okay. And the man who makes him a symbol is Voltaire, is that right? Absolutely. So Voltaire, the great philosoph, polemicist, wit, who in the long run will become
我们喜欢在《历史就是如此》中使用陈词滥调。肯定不是。所以这就是我认为铁面人之所以有如此共鸣的原因，因为他似乎象征着与凡尔赛宫的光芒相对的黑暗。这种感觉是任何人都可以消失在皇家堡垒中，身份本身可以被抹去，一旦你被锁在堡垒里，就有眼睛一直在监视你。所以我认为在18世纪，铁面人成为了这种象征。好的。而让他成为象征的人是伏尔泰，对吗？绝对是。所以伏尔泰，伟大的哲学家、论战家、机智的人，从长远来看，他将成为
one of the people who helps to inspire the French Revolution. And the French Revolution, of course, casts itself as being set against the tyranny and absolutism of the French monarchy. The man in the iron mask, again, he's playing a role in that kind of demonology. And it is Voltaire who basically creates him and who coins the phrase, the man in the iron mask. So Voltaire comes across the story of the man in the iron mask because he himself ends up in the Bastille. So he gets sent there in 1717. So that's two years after the death of Louis XIV. And it's the measure of how long Louis has ruled that Louis is succeeded not by his son, not by his grandson, but by his great grandson. So he, of course, inevitably is also called Louis. So louis the 15th and you need to have a
帮助激励法国大革命的人之一。当然，法国大革命将自己定位为反对法国君主制的暴政和绝对主义。铁面人，再次，他在那种恶魔学中扮演了一个角色。正是伏尔泰基本上创造了他，并创造了“铁面人”这个词。所以伏尔泰偶然发现了铁面人的故事，因为他自己最终进了巴士底狱。所以他在1717年被送到了那里。所以那是路易十四去世两年后。路易统治时间之长，以至于路易的继任者不是他的儿子，不是他的孙子，而是他的曾孙。所以他，当然，不可避免地也被称为路易。所以路易十五，你需要有一个
regent so the guy who rules as regent for louis the 15th is his great uncle the duke of orleans and the duke of orleans is quite a scandalous figure and is darkly rumored to have been having an incestuous relationship with his own daughter dominic okay that's poor conduct tom even for a well even for a frenchman even for a French nobleman. Yeah. So Voltaire can't resist making a joke about this. The Duke of Orleans is furious, has him arrested, chucked into the Bastille. And while Voltaire is there, he is able to learn stories of the man in the iron mask
摄政王，所以为路易十五担任摄政王的人是他的叔祖父奥尔良公爵，奥尔良公爵是一个相当丑闻的人物，有黑暗的传言说他与自己的女儿有乱伦关系，多米尼克。好的，汤姆，即使对于一个，嗯，即使对于一个法国人，即使对于一个法国贵族来说，那也是糟糕的行为。是的。所以伏尔泰忍不住拿这个开玩笑。奥尔良公爵大怒，让他被捕，扔进巴士底狱。当伏尔泰在那里时，他能够了解到铁面人的故事
who died only 14 years previously. So he gets information from the jailers, gets information from the various prisoners. And when he gets released, he keeps his notes. And decades pass, and then in 1751, so a few decades after he's been released, he publishes a book called The Century of Louis XIV. And in this book, there is an entire chapter about the man in the iron mask. And this is where the guy gets defined for all time as wearing an iron mask. And Voltaire describes it. And so he says that it has a chin piece with steel springs that enabled the prisoner to eat while wearing it. And the mask itself is a kind of helmet, like a kind of big egg that's been soldered around his head. So very
他仅仅在14年前去世。所以他从狱卒那里得到信息，从各种囚犯那里得到信息。当他被释放时，他保留了他的笔记。几十年过去了，然后在1751年，也就是他被释放几十年后，他出版了一本名为《路易十四时代》的书。在这本书里，有一整章是关于铁面人的。这就是这个家伙被定义为戴着铁面具的地方。伏尔泰描述了它。所以他说它有一个带有钢弹簧的下巴片，使囚犯在戴着它时可以吃东西。面具本身是一种头盔，就像一个焊接在他头上的大蛋。所以非常
like the description that we got in the Dumas passage that you read at the start. His guards have orders to kill him if he so much as kind of tries to shift it too much. You know, any hint that he's trying to take it off, that's no good. But here is the strange thing. Even as the prisoner has to suffer this excruciating imposition, he is also treated with the utmost respect. So Voltaire describes the Marquis du Louvois, the minister of war who had sentenced him. He comes into the presence of the man in the iron mask and he stands while the man in the iron mask sits. And this is incredible because the age of Louis XIV is an age where etiquette and propriety and hierarchy are absolute principles. So the idea that a Marquis would stand up in the presence of a sitting common prisoner is unthinkable.
像你在开头读到的仲马段落中的描述。他的守卫有命令，如果他稍微试图移动它，就杀了他。你知道，任何他试图摘下它的暗示，那都不行。但这里奇怪的事情是。即使囚犯不得不忍受这种极其痛苦的强加，他也受到了极大的尊重。所以伏尔泰描述了卢福瓦侯爵，那个判他刑的战争大臣。他来到铁面人的面前，当铁面人坐着时，他站着。这太不可思议了，因为路易十四时代是一个礼仪、得体和等级制度是绝对原则的时代。所以一个侯爵在一个坐着的普通囚犯面前站起来的想法是不可想象的。
So then the question is, well, who is this mysterious figure? Somebody noble or whatever, presumably. Well, that's the implication. And yet here is a further puzzle, which Voltaire himself draws attention to. So I'll quote him. Here is the astonishing thing. Even as the prisoner was being sent to the Ile de Saint-Marguerite, so this is the island where he gets taken over by Saint-Mars, no man of any consequence in Europe was reported to have disappeared. Yet such the prisoner undoubtedly was. For during his first few days on the island, he was served his meals by the
所以问题是，好吧，这个神秘的人物是谁？大概是某个贵族什么的。嗯，这就是暗示。然而这里有一个进一步的谜题，伏尔泰本人也提请注意。所以我引用他的话。这是令人震惊的事情。即使当囚犯被送往圣玛格丽特岛时，也就是他被圣马尔带到的那个岛，据报道欧洲没有任何重要人物失踪。然而囚犯无疑就是这样的人。因为在他在岛上的最初几天，他的饭菜是由
governor himself. So a curious case, Holmes. Very, very curious. And well, you know my methods. I think this is a time for a break, isn't it? I think it is time for a break. So after the break, we will return and the Sherlock Holmes of 18th century France, Monsieur Thomas Hollande, will be going through the theories about the man in the eye mask. And Tom, am I right in saying you will be literally unmasking him? Well, not literally. You will be.
总督本人提供的。所以一个奇怪的案件，福尔摩斯。非常，非常奇怪。好吧，你知道我的方法。我想这是休息的时候了，不是吗？我想是休息的时候了。所以休息后，我们将回来，18世纪法国的夏洛克·福尔摩斯，托马斯·霍兰德先生，将梳理关于铁面人的理论。汤姆，我没说错吧，你将真的揭开他的面具？嗯，不是真的。你会的。
I know what you mean. You will be unmasking him. Very exciting. I think I will. Return after the break for this extraordinary drama. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment
我知道你的意思。你将揭开他的面具。非常令人兴奋。我想我会的。休息后回来观看这出非凡的戏剧。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《娱乐就是如此》。这是你每周的娱乐固定节目
news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. To mix my metaphors, my detective metaphors,
新闻、评论、一点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史就是如此》。为了混合我的隐喻，我的侦探隐喻，
the suspects have been assembled in the library, the knight is drawing in, Poirot has closed the curtains, and he turns to face the vicar, the retired colonel, the flapper, and all these other people, and he begins to tell them who was the man in the eye mask. Hercule, take it away, please. Well, so I thought what we could do, is go through the lists of the various candidates that have been proposed to have been the man in the iron mask. And the most famous suggestion, the suggestion that is kind of the great plot driver in Dumas' novel, is the idea that the man in the iron mask is actually somebody who is royal. And this is
嫌疑人已经在图书馆集合，骑士正在撤退，波洛关上了窗帘，他转身面对牧师、退休上校、摩登女郎和所有其他人，他开始告诉他们谁是铁面人。赫尔克里，请开始吧。好吧，所以我认为我们可以做的是，列出各种被提议为铁面人的候选人名单。最著名的建议，在仲马的小说中作为伟大情节驱动力的建议，是铁面人实际上是一个皇室成员的想法。这是
what Voltaire in his book had been hinting at. And in fact, in 1771, he openly confirms it. He states blankly that the man in the iron mask was an elder brother of Louis XIV. And this is Voltaire's own theory, but it exists in the context of what is indisputably a historical fact, which is that Louis XIII, who is Louis XIV's father, and his mother, Anne of Austria, who despite being called that is actually from Spain, had real trouble in getting an heir. So Louis XIV was born 23 years after his parents had been married. And when he was born, it was so surprising that the infant boy came to be known as Dieu Donne, God-given. It seemed to be a miracle. And so where there are miracles, there are people who are keen to debunk them.
伏尔泰在他的书中暗示过的。事实上，在1771年，他公开证实了这一点。他直截了当地说，铁面人是路易十四的哥哥。这是伏尔泰自己的理论，但它存在于一个无可争议的历史事实的背景下，即路易十三，也就是路易十四的父亲，和他的母亲奥地利安娜，尽管名字叫那个，实际上来自西班牙，在获得继承人方面确实有困难。所以路易十四是在他父母结婚23年后出生的。当他出生时，这太令人惊讶了，以至于这个婴儿被称为“上帝赐予的”。这似乎是一个奇迹。所以哪里有奇迹，哪里就有热衷于揭穿它们的人。
And there were various theories as to who Louis XIV's father might actually have been, because the idea was that, well, it had taken so long, so obviously Louis XIII was having trouble getting his wife pregnant. So if not Louis XIII, then who? So inevitably, one popular theory is Cardinal Mazarin. Of course. Because everyone loves a sexually predatory cardinal in the 17th century. We do, yeah.
关于路易十四的父亲实际上可能是谁，有各种理论，因为想法是，好吧，这花了太长时间，所以显然路易十三在让他的妻子怀孕方面有困难。所以如果不是路易十三，那会是谁？所以不可避免地，一个流行的理论是马扎然红衣主教。当然。因为每个人都喜欢17世纪的性掠夺红衣主教。我们喜欢，是的。
And to be fair, he had actually been very close to Anne of Austria. The two were kind of very close political allies. Another theory was the Duke of Buckingham, who was the favourite of James I of England, James VI of Scotland. Of course, very long legs. Very long legs, swathed in silk, friend of the guy who becomes Charles I, and who appears in The Three Musketeers. Yes, he does.
公平地说，他实际上与奥地利安娜非常亲近。两人是某种非常亲密的政治盟友。另一个理论是白金汉公爵，他是英国国王詹姆斯一世、苏格兰国王詹姆斯六世的最爱。当然，腿很长。腿很长，裹在丝绸里，是那个后来成为查理一世的人的朋友，他出现在《三个火枪手》中。是的，他确实出现了。
So he's a kind of big character in that. And in fact, the Duke of Buckingham had visited Paris in 1625 with the future Charles I and was rumoured to have had a relationship with Anne. So these are the swirl of rumours that lie behind gossip about who Louis XIV's father was. And all Voltaire does is to ratchet up the degree of scandal by saying that actually, Louis XIV was the son of Louis XIII and Anne of Austria, so he was legitimate. But there was this illegitimate elder brother who was floating around. This is the one who had to be locked up, had to be kept safely out of the way. Right, right, right. Yeah.
所以他是那部作品中的一个大角色。事实上，白金汉公爵曾在1625年与未来的查理一世访问过巴黎，并有传言说他与安娜有染。所以这些是关于路易十四的父亲是谁的流言蜚语背后的传闻。伏尔泰所做的只是通过说路易十四实际上是路易十三和奥地利安娜的儿子，所以他是合法的，来提高丑闻的程度。但有一个非法的哥哥在四处游荡。这就是那个必须被关起来，必须被安全地保持在视线之外的人。对，对，对。是的。
So that's Voltaire's theory. But there is another theory that is actually earlier than Voltaire's, which in a way is even more sensational and in fact makes more sense. And that is that the man in the iron mask isn't just Louis XIV's brother, but his identical twin brother. Oh my word. This is Leonardo DiCaprio, isn't it? Yeah. So this is what drives the plot in Dumas' novel.
所以那是伏尔泰的理论。但还有另一个理论，实际上比伏尔泰的更早，在某种程度上甚至更耸人听闻，事实上更有意义。那就是铁面人不仅是路易十四的兄弟，而且是他的同卵双胞胎兄弟。哦，我的天。这就是莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥，不是吗？是的。所以这就是驱动仲马小说情节的原因。
Because of course, if it's an identical twin, then who's to say which is the king and which is the prisoner? I mean, lots of scope for a romantic novelist. But actually, it's not invented by Dumas. It's originally reported in a letter to another of the great philosophers of the 18th century, Denis Diderot, a famous atheist, author of the great encyclopedia. And he says that he's heard it from a German journalist who had heard it from the niece of Louis XIV, who had heard it from her father, who heard it from Louis XV,
因为当然，如果是同卵双胞胎，那么谁能说哪个是国王，哪个是囚犯？我的意思是，浪漫小说家有很多发挥空间。但实际上，它不是仲马发明的。它最初是在给18世纪另一位伟大的哲学家丹尼斯·狄德罗的一封信中报道的，他是一位著名的无神论者，伟大百科全书的作者。他说他从一位德国记者那里听到的，那位记者从路易十四的侄女那里听到的，她从她父亲那里听到的，她从路易十五那里听到的，
who of course is the great grandson and heir of Louis XIV. Okay. So that seems a very plausible chain of transmission. Yeah, in that case, it's obviously true. I mean, no doubt about it. And the story is that Anne of Austria goes into labour. She gives birth to the future Louis XIV. It's all done in public. Everyone's kind of gathering around to witness the birth of the heir. The baby future Louis XIV is carried off, fireworks, gunfire, all that kind of thing.
当然，他是路易十四的曾孙和继承人。好的。所以这似乎是一个非常合理的传播链。是的，在这种情况下，它显然是真的。我的意思是，毫无疑问。故事是奥地利安娜开始分娩。她生下了未来的路易十四。这一切都是公开完成的。每个人都聚集在一起见证继承人的出生。婴儿未来的路易十四被带走，烟花、枪声，所有这些事情。
Hurrah, hurrah. Anne of Austria collapses back into her pillows, exhausted by the strains of labor. And then four hours later, contractions start again. And she gives birth to this second twin, identical twin. And the reason why this would be threatening to Louis XIV, to have an identical twin who's born four hours after him isn't just the danger that their identities could be confused, but also that according to a theory that was very popular in France in the 17th century, the twin that is born second had been conceived first. Okay. I suppose there's a weird biological logic in that is there yeah well let's not go into it too deeply as it were um so this might give people who wanted to
万岁，万岁。奥地利安娜因分娩的压力而精疲力竭，倒回枕头上。然后四小时后，宫缩再次开始。她生下了这个第二个双胞胎，同卵双胞胎。而这之所以会对路易十四构成威胁，拥有一个在他出生四小时后出生的同卵双胞胎，不仅是因为他们的身份可能被混淆的危险，而且还因为根据17世纪法国非常流行的一种理论，第二个出生的双胞胎是先受孕的。好的。我想这其中有一种奇怪的生物学逻辑，是吗？是的，好吧，我们不要太深入地探讨它，我的意思是，嗯，所以这可能会给那些想要的人
get rid of louis the 14th you know justification and opportunity and so this is why the unfortunate twin brother has been banged up right that, I think, is an excellent theory. There is one final theory, which actually originated in the 20th century with a Tory MP. So that's Lord Quickswood. He was part of the Cecil family, the big Cecil dynasty. So he was Lord Hugh Cecil, he was, and he was Churchill's best man, Tom. And he had a big moustache, did he? He had an enormous moustache.
摆脱路易十四，你知道，理由和机会，所以这就是为什么那个不幸的双胞胎兄弟被关起来的原因，对吧，我认为这是一个极好的理论。还有一个最终理论，实际上起源于20世纪，由一位保守党议员提出。那就是奎克斯伍德勋爵（Lord Quickswood）。他是塞西尔家族的一员，那个庞大的塞西尔王朝。所以他是休·塞西尔勋爵（Lord Hugh Cecil），他是丘吉尔的伴郎，汤姆。他留着大胡子，是吗？他留着巨大的胡子。
Right. I'll tell you what, he would not be popular with the community manager of our Rest His History club, James Regan, because he was a sworn foe of H.H. Asquith. And James is a massive Asquith fan, as we know. Of course he is. Yes, of course he is. Okay. But, I mean, that doesn't necessarily invalidate him. No.
没错。我告诉你，他肯定不会受到我们“历史余音”（Rest Is History）俱乐部社区经理詹姆斯·里根（James Regan）的欢迎，因为他是H.H.阿斯奎斯（H.H. Asquith）的死敌。而正如我们所知，詹姆斯是阿斯奎斯的超级粉丝。他当然是。是的，他当然是。好吧。但是，我的意思是，这并不一定能否定他的观点。不。
As a kind of a scholar of… Of the man in the iron mask. The man in the iron mask. So he comes up with a great theory. And his theory is that the man in the iron mask. So he comes up with a great theory. And his theory is that the man in the iron mask wasn't Louis XIV's brother, but his father. And his theory is that Richelieu, who is Louis XIII's agent, you know, chief minister, is very, very anxious that Louis XIII doesn't have an heir. Because if he doesn't have an heir, then the next king is someone
作为“铁面人”研究的学者。铁面人。所以他提出了一个伟大的理论。他的理论是，铁面人不是路易十四的兄弟，而是他的父亲。他的理论是，路易十三的代理人，也就是首席大臣黎塞留（Richelieu），非常非常担心路易十三没有继承人。因为如果他没有继承人，那么下一任国王就是黎塞留的死敌。所以他绝对决心让奥地利的安娜（Anne of Austria）怀孕。所以基本上他雇佣了一个替身父亲。一个种马。来完成这项任务，一个种马。奥地利的安娜如愿怀孕了。然后这个种马被黎塞留打发走了。他被打包送过大西洋去美国生活。人们期望再也不会听到关于他的消息。问题是，当路易十四成年时，敲门的竟然是爸爸。哦，不。他试图勒索他的儿子。
who's a sworn enemy of Richelieu. So he's absolutely determined to get Anne of Austria pregnant. And so basically he employs a substitute father. A stud. To do the business, a stud. And Anne of Austria duly gets pregnant. And the stud is then paid off by Richelieu. He's packed across the Atlantic to go and live in America. And the expectation is that no more will be heard of him. The problem is that when Louis XIV comes of age, who should come knocking at the door but Papa. Oh no. And he's trying to blackmail his son.
非常愚蠢。所以路易绝不接受这一点。于是父亲被流放到监狱系统，并被迫戴上面具。事情就这样结束了。现在，你可能想知道，这有什么证据吗？奎克斯伍德勋爵非常愉快地承认，根本没有任何证据。但他确实觉得这符合所有事实。它确实符合所有事实。我的意思是，这是一个伟大的理论。所以是他的父亲，那个种马，一直在试图勒索路易。但正如你所说，如果没有证据，我认为我们真的无法接受那个理论，汤姆。我认为所有这些理论的问题在于，它们是小说的绝佳素材。但通常，历史的教训之一是，如果某件事是小说的绝佳素材，
Very foolish. And so Louis is not having that. And so the father banishes into the prison system and is made to wear a mask. And that is the end of that. Now, you may wonder, what is the evidence for this? And Lord Quickswood very cheerfully admitted there was no evidence for it whatsoever. But he did feel that it fitted all the facts. It does fit all the facts. I mean, it's a great theory. So it's his father, the stud, who's been trying to blackmail Louis. But as you say, if there's no evidence, I don't think we can really embrace that theory, Tom. I think the problem with all of these is that they are brilliant material for a novel. But generally, one of the lessons of history is that if stuff is brilliant material for a novel,
它很可能并没有发生。你不觉得吗？我的意思是，令人沮丧的是。我是说，我在想肯尼迪（JFK）。是的。是的。但是，你知道，令人兴奋和迷人的刺客。是的。可能不是。你知道谁会写一部关于这个的精彩小说吗？丹·布朗（Dan Brown），是的，他会写，不是吗？他非常像是“历史余音”的成员，普里奥里（Priory）什么的，我会支持它或者别的什么。总之，继续吧，所以我认为这些理论中没有一个是绝对被排除的，我认为它们是有可能的，但我认为它们
it probably didn't happen. Don't you think? I mean, depressingly. I mean, I'm thinking of JFK. Yes. Yeah. But, you know, exciting and glamorous assassins. Yes. Probably not. Do you know who would write a brilliant novel about this? Ren dan brown yeah he would wouldn't he very much an associate of the register's history the priori to say i would be behind it or something anyway go on so i don't think any of those are absolutely ruled out i think they are possibilities but i think they're
很可能不是真的。是的，不过还有另一条线索，听众可能还记得，当铁面人去世并被埋葬时，在他死后不久写下的死亡记录中，给了他一个名字。哦，是的，马尔谢先生（Monsieur de Marchiel）。马尔谢先生。那么那个呢？有没有证据表明有一位马尔谢先生得罪了路易十四？令人沮丧的事实是，并没有，对吧，根本没有任何关于他的证据，学者们知道这一点，因为在法国大革命之后，巴士底狱的所有文件都被公开了，它们被散落各处，最终流落到俄罗斯，又被带回法国，还有其他记录，所以学者们已经翻遍了所有这些文件
probably unlikely okay to be true yeah there is another lead, however, and listeners may remember that when the man in the iron mask died and was buried, an entry was put into the record of his death, written shortly after, giving him his name. Oh yeah, Monsieur de Marchiel. Monsieur de Marchiel. So what about that? Is there any evidence of a Monsieur de Marchiel having fallen foul of Louis XIV? And and the depressing truth is there isn't right there's no evidence of him at all and scholars know this because in the wake of the french revolution all the papers from the bastille get released they kind of get scattered they end up in russia they get brought back to france other records as well and so scholars have been through all these papers
用细齿梳子梳理了一遍，根本没有提到马尔谢（Martial）。所以他们转而寻找我们知道可能被关在监狱系统里，名字以M开头的人。确实有这样一个人物。这是一个意大利人，他是一位伯爵，名叫埃科莱·马蒂奥利（Eccole Mattioli）。这家伙非常愚蠢地试图欺骗路易十四，所以他被法国间谍机构雇佣，然后他试图，你知道，成为双重间谍，路易十四发现了，并派人绑架了他，把他带到了皮内罗洛（Pignerol），那是富凯（Fouquet）被关押的伟大监狱，是的，高耸在阿尔卑斯山上，俯瞰着意大利。马蒂奥利和富凯一起被关在皮内罗洛。他被赋予了一个假名以掩盖身份。他受到圣马尔（St. Maas）的非常、
with a fine tooth comb and there is no mention at all of a Martial. So instead they have looked for somebody who we know might have been imprisoned in the prison system, whose name begins with M. And there is such a character. And this is an Italian, he's a count and he's called Eccole Mattioli. And this is a guy who very foolishly tried to double cross louis the 14th so he was employed by the french spy service he then tried to you know be a double agent louis the 14th found out and had him kidnapped abducted and brought to pignerol which is the great prison uh where fouquet was in prison yeah high in the alps looking out out over Italy. And Mattioli is imprisoned in Pignerol alongside Fouquet. He is given a false name to disguise his identity. He is kept under very,
非常严密的监视。有人在监听他说的每一句话。他和另一个人关在一起，一个疯了的僧侣。据报道，马蒂奥利曾吹嘘说他知道的比他能说的多，他掌握着可能推翻君主制的秘密。好吧。他是一个很好的候选人，汤姆。他确实是一个很好的候选人。我想说，直到最近，他可能还是被人们认为最可能是铁面人的候选人，然而，新发现的圣马尔写的信件揭示，尽管
very close watch by St. Maas. Someone is listening into everything he says. And he gets imprisoned with another guy, a monk who goes mad. And Mattioli is reported to have boasted that he knew more than he could say, that he had secrets that would potentially bring down the monarchy. Okay. He's a good candidate, Tom. He is a good candidate. And I would say that until recently, he was probably the candidate who was viewed by people as being the likeliest person to be the man in the iron mask however new letters written by san marz have been found and they reveal that although
马蒂奥利被带到了圣玛格丽特（San Margarite），但他可能不久后就去世了，而且他绝对从未被带到巴士底狱，所以不是他。所以不是他。在我们进入你认为真正的那个人之前，还有一个更复杂的理论。好吧，那里有几个非常复杂的理论。它们都认为监狱是在英国。是的。所以其中一个是1687年。圣马尔写了一封信，信中说住在监狱附近的人认为这可能是奥利弗·克伦威尔（Oliver Cromwell）的儿子。
amatioli was taken down to san margarite he probably died shortly afterwards and he was definitely never taken to the bastille so it's not him so it's not him before we get into the person who you think it really was there there is an even more elaborate theory. Well, there are a couple of really elaborate theories on there. And they're both that the prison was English. Yeah. So one of them was 1687. Sam Mars writes a letter in which he says the people who live near the prison think that this might be the son of Oliver Cromwell.
奇怪的是。但不可能。不，因为其中一个已经死了，另一个在流亡。是的，理查德·克伦威尔（Richard Cromwell），“倒霉的迪克”（Tumble down Dick）。是的，他活了很久很久。所以不是他。是的，他确实活了。
Bizarrely. But couldn't be. No, because one of them is dead and another one is in exile. Yeah. Richard Cromwell, tumble down dick. Yeah, he lives forever and ever. So it's not him. Yes, he does.
是的。他一直活到安妮女王（Queen Anne）统治时期，所以绝对不是他。是的。那另一个是什么？蒙茅斯公爵（Duke of Monmouth）。是的。这在18世纪再次被提出。
Yeah. He lived into the reign of Queen Anne and it's definitely not him. Yeah. And then what's the other one? The Duke of Monmouth. Yeah. This is proposed again in the 18th century.
所以这是一个相当古老的理论。蒙茅斯公爵是查理二世（Charles II）的私生子，领导了一场反对他叔叔詹姆斯二世（James II）的叛乱，结果被击败。他被带到伦敦塔，非常可怕地被斩首了。是的，被一个叫凯奇（Ketch）的人，砍了大约57下。事实上，蒙茅斯在行刑后还站起来说，继续。
So it's quite a venerable one. And the Duke of Monmouth is the bastard son of Charles II, leads a rebellion against his uncle, James II, gets defeated. He gets taken to the tower, gets beheaded very horribly. Yeah, by a man called Ketch, who took about 57 strokes. And actually, Monmouth got up after the execution and said, carry on.
他的头几乎挂在脖子上。别磨蹭了。所以显然不是他。不，我的意思是，显然不是他，因为他被处决了。但理论是，也许他被掉包了，但我的意思是，他没有。那是一次非常公开的处决。而且还有另一个致命的细节，那就是人们确实听到了铁面人说话，没有人记录他有英国口音，或者意大利口音。所以他似乎确实是法国人。也许像我一样，汤姆，他只是说了漂亮的法语。也许，也许。但我认为可能的解释是他就是法国人。老实说，
His head was kind of hanging off. Stop messing around. So it's obviously not him. No, I mean, it's obviously not him because he was executed. But the theory is that perhaps he got switched, but I mean, he didn't. It was a very public execution. And also there is another killer detail, which is that people did hear the man in the iron mask speak and nobody records that he had an English accent or indeed an Italian accent. So he does seem to have been French. Perhaps like me, Tom, he just spoke beautiful French. Maybe, maybe. But I think the likely explanation is that he's French. And to be honest,
对所有现有文献的深入研究，这实际上只发生在20世纪60年代，自20世纪60年代以来，学者们基本上已经能够确定铁面人到底是谁了。有一些关键文件证明了这一点。这些文件是在铁面人最早被提及之前很久写成的。它们一直追溯到1669年7月。这些是路易十四和卢福瓦（Louvois）写给圣马尔的信，当时他是皮内罗洛的指挥官，告诉他要迎接一名囚犯。我们还有路易十四为同一名囚犯签发的“密令”（Lettre de Cachet）。
the kind of the close study of all the available documentation, which really only happened in the 1960s, it's been since the 1960s that scholars have essentially been able to identify who the man in the iron mask actually was. And there are some key documents which show this. And these were written long before the earliest mention of the man in the iron mask. And they go all the way back to July, 1669. And these are letters that were written by Louis XIV and Louvois to St. Mars, who is then, you know, he's the commander of Pignerol, telling him to expect a prisoner. And we also have the Lettre de Cachet, which was issued by Louis XIV for this same prisoner.
所以我们知道这名囚犯的名字，是多米尼克（Dominic）。是的。是尤斯塔什·德·热（Eustache de Gé）。所以，汤姆，令人失望的是，按照侦探小说的标准，这是你之前根本没有提到过的人。是的，我知道。我知道。那么尤斯塔什·多热（Eustache Doge）到底是谁？好吧，根据文件，他是一个可怜虫，一个恶棍。
So we know the name of this prisoner, and it was Dominic. Yes. It was Eustache de Gé. So, Tom, disappointingly, by the standards of a detective novel, this is somebody that you've not previously mentioned at all. Yeah, I know. I know. So who on earth is Eustache Doge? Well, so according to the documents, he is a wretch, a villain.
他在加来（Calais）被捕。他将被严格隔离。如果他谈论任何超出他最基本需求和要求的事情，圣马尔就要杀了他。有一个有趣的细节，我认为对于我们这些听着侯爵站在囚犯面前的故事长大的人来说，这是相当出乎意料的，那就是尤斯塔什·多热只是一个男仆。好吧。那么为什么总督要站在他面前并为他端饭什么的呢？在我们讨论这个问题之前，我们可以追踪这个家伙在整个监狱系统中的轨迹。所以从1669年一直到1703年。所以他被关在皮内罗洛，他被关在
He's been arrested in Calais. He is to be kept in strict isolation. Sam Mars is to kill him if he talks about anything than his most basic needs and requirements. And there is an intriguing detail, which I think is rather unexpected for all of us who have been brought up on tales of Marquis standing in the presence of the prisoner, which is that Eustache Doge is only a valet. Okay. So why on earth was the governor standing in his presence and serving him his meals and stuff? Before we come to that question, we can track this guy right the way through the prison system. So all the way from 1669 to 1703. So he gets imprisoned in Pignerol, he gets imprisoned in
埃克西尔（Exiles），他被关在圣玛格丽特，他被关在巴士底狱。所以很明显，这是唯一一个可能是蒙面人的人，他被看到被带到圣玛格丽特，然后到达巴士底狱。所以基本上必须是这个家伙，必须是尤斯塔什·多热。但当然，问题是，尤斯塔什·多热可能是一个化名吗？我的意思是，这可能是一个侯爵确实会站在他面前的人的化名吗？我的意思是，他被关在为那些被认为对国家危险的人准备的监狱里。
Exiles, he gets imprisoned in Saint-Marguerite, and he gets imprisoned in the Bastille. So it's clear this is the only guy who could have been the masked man who is seen being taken over to Saint-Marguerite and then arriving in the Bastille. So basically it has to be this guy, it has to be Eustache Doger. But of course, the question then is, well, might Eustache Doger be a pseudonym? I mean, might it be the pseudonym of someone in whose presence a Marquis would indeed stand? I mean, he is being housed in a prison for those considered dangerous to the state.
他被那些伯爵之类的人包围着。路易十四和卢福瓦似乎都对他个人很感兴趣。同样，如果他只是一个男仆，这就很奇怪了。逮捕令上的名字似乎是在“密令”本身写好之后才加上去的。然后，当然，还有一个问题，他为什么要戴着？
He's being surrounded by people who are counts and so on. Louis XIV and Louvois both seem to have taken a personal interest in him. Again, quite odd if he's just a valet. The name on the arrest warrant appears to have been added after the Lettre de Cachet itself was actually written. And then, of course, there's the question, why is he wearing?
为什么要戴面具？面具。是的。但是，多米尼克，我的意思是，让我们看看另一种理论。是的，让我们看看。在处理侦探案件时，我们应该总是这样做。是的。假设，为了论证，
Why the mask? A mask. Yeah. But, Dominic, I mean, let's look at an alternative theory. Yeah, let's. We should always do that when engaging in detective cases. Yeah. Let's suppose, for the sake of argument,
尤斯塔什·德·热正是卢福瓦所说的那样。换句话说，一个男仆，绅士的男仆，一种吉夫斯（Jeeves）式的人物。当然，我从伏尔泰（Voltaire）那里读到的那段话支持这种可能性，他说没有任何重要人物失踪。在欧洲，是的。我的意思是，你知道，因为如果他只是一个男仆，
that Eustache de Gé was exactly what Louvois said he was. In other words, a valet, a gentleman's gentleman, a kind of Jeeves figure. And of course, there's backup for this possibility in that passage that I read from Voltaire, where he said that no one of any significance had vanished. In Europe, yeah. I mean, you know, because if it's just a valet,
没人会在意，对吧？不。而且我认为有一个致命的、事实上是决定性的细节，那就是在皮内罗洛，我们知道尤斯塔什·德·热被迫做男仆的工作。哦，对了。所以富凯，他的男仆，我不记得是死了还是怎么的。所以尤斯塔什·德·热作为男仆为富凯工作，如果他真的是贵族，更不用说皇室身份，这是不可想象的。但这直接反驳了你之前提到的那个总督站在他面前并为他端饭的说法，
no one would care, would they? No. And there is an, I think, kind of killer, in fact, a clinching detail, which is that in Pignerol, we know that Eustache de Gea was made to work as a valet. Oh, right. So Fouquet, his valet, I can't remember, dies or something. And so Eustache de Gea works for Fouquet as his valet, which is unthinkable if he'd actually been of noble or let alone royal status. But then that directly contradicts that account that you gave earlier that the governor stood in his presence and served him his meals,
因为总督永远不会对一个普通的男仆那样做，汤姆。他不会，但这个故事是从哪里来的？它来自几十年后写作的伏尔泰，他非常有偏见，众所周知，如果他要提出一个论点，他会通过夸大来提出。伏尔泰就是《卫报》的新闻标准，汤姆。非常好。非常好。你的中右翼玩笑，多米尼克。
because the governor would never have done that to a mere valet, Tom. He wouldn't, but where is the story coming from? It's coming from Voltaire, who's writing decades later and is very party-pre and is well known to, if he's got a case to make, he will make that case by exaggerating. Voltaire is the journalistic standards of The Guardian, Tom. Very good. Very good. Your centre-right banter, Donny.
哦，非常好。好吧，所以基本上故事的很大一部分来自伏尔泰。我的意思是，他借鉴了一个显然被迫戴面具的囚犯，即使不是铁制的。但所有关于人们站在他面前的事情，我的意思是，他很容易编造出来。我认为证据表明他确实编造了。面具呢？那是编造的吗？不，那显然不是编造的，因为我们有这些不同的同时代的证据。所以那显然不是编造的。但同样，你不得不怀疑，这是否是圣马尔的一种炫耀？因为你提到的关于人们说囚犯是克伦威尔的儿子那件事，他是带着某种自豪的语气说的。我们从他写的其他
Oh, very good. Right, so basically so much of the story comes from Voltaire. I mean, he is drawing on a prisoner who clearly had been made to wear a mask, even if not of iron. But all the stuff about people standing in his presence, I mean, he could very easily have made that up. And I think that the evidence suggests that he did make it up. What about the mask? Is that made up? No, that's clearly not made up because we have these different contemporaneous pieces of evidence for that. So that clearly isn't being made up. But again, you have to wonder, is this kind of showboating perhaps by Sanmas? Because that thing that you mentioned about people saying that the prisoner is the son of Cromwell, he's saying this in a tone of some pride. And we know from other
通信中知道，他说，我讲了一些关于囚犯的夸张故事。我想是因为他知道他戴着面具这一事实使他成为八卦的话题。这为圣马尔赢得了声誉。它使路易十四和卢福瓦感到……没有命令让囚犯戴面具。所以据我们所知，这似乎是圣马尔本人在做这件事。所以我认为可能的解释是他就是卢福瓦所说的那样，他是一个男仆，所有那些让人们认为他可能是皇室成员的事情，都是伏尔泰夸大的，他有他自己的理由这样做。所以如果他是一个男仆，我的意思是，为什么他引起了路易十四的兴趣？男仆是权势人物的贴身随从。所以这使他们处于看到他们不应该看到的事情的最佳位置，如果你考虑到他在哪里被捕以及我们说他是在1669年在加来被捕，
correspondence that he's written that he says, I have told kind of exaggerated stories about the prisoner. I think because he knows that the fact that he's wearing a mask makes him a topic of gossip. And this redounds to St. Mars' credit. It makesIV and Louvois, there's no orders to put the prisoner in a mask. So as far as we can tell, this seems to have been Saint-Mars himself who is doing it. So I think that the likely explanation is that he is what Louvois said, that he was a valet and that all the kind of stuff that have made people think perhaps he was a member of the royal family, was exaggerated by Voltaire, who had his own reasons for doing that. So if he was a valet though, I mean, why has he attracted the interest of Louis XIV? And valets are close attendants on very powerful people. And so that puts them in prime position to see things perhaps that they shouldn't and if you bear in mind where he's arrested and when we said he was arrested in Calais in Calais in 1669 okay so the obvious implication of that so Calais of course across the channel from Dover
那么这隐含的意思是——加来当然在多佛（Dover）海峡对面——在17世纪60年代末，英国的查理二世正在与法国的路易十四秘密谈判一项协议，这将成为对此的进一步转折，即查理二世，他实际上是一个天主教徒，并且想成为天主教徒，但不是公开的，他将公开皈依天主教，并大概带领他的国家回到罗马天主教会的怀抱，当然他从未这样做，对吧，汤姆？他违背了协议的那部分，因为他知道这会让他失去王位。但尤斯塔什·多热是参与谈判的某人的男仆，你认为这合理吗？所以这是一个被许多历史学家提出的理论。我的意思是，这当然有可能，也许他是卢福瓦自己的男仆。也许他是某人的男仆
and at the end of the 1660s Charles II of England is in secret talks with Louis XIV of France about a deal which will become the a further twist to this, which is that Charles II, who effectively is a Catholic and would like to be a Catholic, but not publicly, that he will publicly convert to Catholicism and presumably lead his country back into the fold of the Roman Catholic Church, which of course he never does, does he, Tom? He reneges on that part of the deal because he knows it would cost him his throne. But is it plausible that Eustache Doge was the manservant to somebody involved with the negotiations, do you think? So this is a theory that's been proposed by a number of historians. And I mean, it certainly seems possible that perhaps he was Livoire's own valet. Perhaps he was the valet of someone
参与了谈判。也许他被雇佣为英国间谍，我的意思是，我们不知道，对吧？但逮捕他的时间和地点，因为加来显然，你知道，你可以想象他去那里可能是为了穿过海峡去多佛，这确实表明这是一个非常合理的理论。另一个理论可能是他是一个荷兰间谍，对吧，他在那里反对法国人。还有一个相当复杂的理论，我认为可能性较小，即他挪用了查理一世的遗孀亨丽埃塔·玛丽亚（Henrietta Maria）的钱，她当时住在巴黎，是路易十四的姑姑，所以有很多可能的理论，我认为除非发现更多的通信，否则我们永远不会知道真相。
involved in the negotiations. perhaps he was employed as an english agent i mean we don't know right but the timing and the place where he's arrested because of calais obviously you know you could imagine that he's going there to perhaps to cross to dover does suggest that this is a very plausible theory another theory might be that he is a dutch agent right that he's kind of working against the french there's also a quite complicated theory that i think is less probable that he had embezzled money from charles i widow henrietta maria yeah who was living in paris at the time lou the 14th aunt so lots of possible theories and i think unless further correspondence is discovered, we will never know the actual truth.
所以有一位名叫乔治·芒格雷迪安（Georges Mangredien）的历史学家，他在60年代基本上汇编了所有文件。虽然他从未说他认为那是谁，但很明显他认为那是尤斯塔什·多热。他建议可能还有更多的通信有待发现。所以这是一种可能，可能确实会揭示多热到底做了什么。但我的意思是，我们不知道。但我认为整个故事很有趣，因为它是一个经典的例证，说明试图掩盖某事反而会引起人们的注意
So there's a historian called Georges Mangredien, who was the guy who, in the 60s, basically compiled all the documentation. And although he never said who he thought it was, it's pretty clear that he thought it was Eustache Doge. And he suggested that there might be further correspondence to be discovered. So that is one possibility that might conceivably reveal that Doget, what he'd actually done. But I mean, we don't know. But I think that the whole story is intriguing because it's a kind of classic illustration that trying to cover something up can draw attention
。我的意思是，这就是水门事件（Watergate）的教训，不是吗？对。烧掉磁带。所以铁面人在某种程度上是路易十四的水门事件，你可以这么说。对。试图将这个家伙彻底遗忘的尝试反而使他变得极其出名，尽管我们仍然无法完全确定他到底做了什么。所以这是一个有趣的故事，我认为有一个解决方案。对。太迷人了。所以其中的教训是，如果你试图取消某人，汤姆，人们会在300年后还在谈论他们。
to it. I mean, it's the lesson of Watergate, isn't it? Right. Burn the tapes. So the man in the unmask in a way is Louis XIV's Watergate, you might say. Right. That the attempt to bury this guy in complete oblivion has made him incredibly famous, even though we still can't be absolutely certain as to what he did. So an intriguing story, I think with a kind of solution. Right. Fascinating. So the lesson of that is if you try to cancel somebody, Tom, people will be talking about them 300 years later.
好吧，在圣马尔写给卢福瓦的一封信中，他吹嘘自己是如何保守囚犯身份的秘密的。他写道，我可以向您保证，阁下，没有人见过他，而且我在旅途中看守和护送他的方式让每个人都试图猜测他是谁。
Well, so in one of the letters that Samar writes to Louvois, he boasts about how he has kept the identity of his prisoner a secret. And he writes, I can assure you, Monsignor, that no one has seen him and that the manner in which I have guarded and conducted him during the journey makes everybody try to guess who he is.
而我们在这里，几个世纪过去了，我们仍然在试图猜测铁面人是谁。非常好，汤姆。一个非常好的结束语。那真是，我敢说，是一次杰作（un tour de force）。啊，谢谢，埃尔库尔（Ercule）或夏洛克（Sherlock）或我之前叫你的任何名字，这真的很有趣，铁面人让谈话结束了，谜团解开了，带着这个重磅炸弹，我们下次再见。谢谢你，汤姆，再见。再见（Au revoir）。
And here we are, centuries on, and we are still trying to guess who the man in the iron mask was. Very good, Tom. A very nice note on which to end. That was, dare I say, un tour de force. Ah oh merci uh thank you uh ericule or sherlock or whatever i was calling you earlier that was really good fun and the man in the iron mask let the conversation end the mystery is solved and on that bombshell we'll see you all next time. Thank you, Tom, and goodbye. Au revoir.
我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐余音》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往……本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐余谈》。这是您每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点演艺圈八卦的来源，在问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的幕后，告诉您这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果您想收听无广告内容、获得额外剧集并优先购买现场演出门票，请前往。本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。